winding down the third and O'Neill is on
hardened
James foul and a shot by
pardon and they're going to take a look
at this a shot to the midsection of
Royce O'Neill
the official Nick Booker calling for the
signal for a replay here
[Applause]
kind of hard to tell from that in here
we'll see it from here
[Applause]
he thought it was oh wow
[Music]
wow
Harden is gone
now you're wondering
was this I hate to see someone of a
make-up call of them not throwing out
Joelle embiid on that play in the first
quarter and look at him B he is
absolutely
befuddled right now O'Neill will be at
the free-throw line and on top Johnson
rearrange it and keeps it inside and
feeds
[Applause]
technical foul yep that's the right call
technical foul on Claxton and I think
he's gone
taunting
right here here's the the dunk
the flex
[Music]
code will be at the line to shoot
the tip Claxton is out
we've had injections both ways got to be
smart about it too though
he was having a
terrific game he sure was
Claxton with 18. that's a new playoff
career high for him
Claxton did not score game two had five
in game one